hi folks I'm drew Carey as you know I'm
from Cleveland Ohio I love Cleveland
Ohio I based my whole career I'm being
from Cleveland Ohio and he also might
know that Cleveland Ohio has gone
through some tough times right now the
economy is in trouble
schools are in trouble and people have
been leaving the city in droves for a
long long time and it's not just
Cleveland it's a lot of cities in the
country are having the same problems and
I went to the folks at The Reason
Foundation and I said is there any way
we can come up with some ideas to help
save Cleveland and we looked at some
best practices at other cities around
the country and we wanted to know if we
applied him to Cleveland would it do any
good the series is called Reason saves
Cleveland hope you like it
[Music]
the post-war years were a golden age for
Cleveland a city built on a rock-solid
foundation of steel mills heavy
manufacturing and shipping in 1950
Cleveland was the sixth largest city in
the United States with a population of
nearly 1 million people the city's
economic strength was mirrored on the
playing fields of the NFL and Major
League Baseball as athletic heroes like
Bob Feller and Lou the tow Groza brought
championships to Cleveland in the 1950s
Northeast Ohio appeared to be a place of
limitless possibilities almost 2 million
people live and work here and recognize
this area as the best location in the
nation
so how did the best location in the
nation to become the mistake on the lake
Cleveland's tale of decline is familiar
to all inhabitants of Rust Belt cities
it's a story punctuated by economic
downturns population decline and social
unrest it was really like a racially
divided City Cleveland you ask anybody
in 1966 racial tensions came to a head
culminating in the Huff race riots as
with Newark and Detroit the rides
created a sense that Cleveland had
become uncover Noble in 1969 as the
nation began to develop an
environmentalist sensibility the
massively polluted Cuyahoga River
actually caught fires providing an
iconic and disturbing image of an
unlivable urban hellhole west of the
beach once down downtown and thought
there's nothing but dead fish all over
that Beach except so was horrible in the
1970s pitched battles about racial
desegregation in Cleveland's public
schools pitted blacks against whites and
liberals against conservatives
what was your initial reaction when you
found out Todd would have to be bused
away well I felt that I'd rather go to
jail than have him bust across town the
busing controversy increased flight from
the city and created an even bleaker
future for Cleveland's public schools
the bad economy of the 1970s had
Cleveland especially hard as heavy
industry jobs increasingly relocated to
the south or outside the United States
altogether and in 1978 under the
guidance of Boyd mayor Dennis Kucinich
Cleveland made history by defaulting on
a 15 million
I mean it was just a nacho the whole
city was by 1980 Cleveland had lost a
third of its population and when the
city's once great sports franchises
weren't slumping they were breaking the
hearts of their fans an infamous
last-minute fumble in the 1988 AFC
Championship game seemed to perfectly
capture the spirit of a city whose
future had slipped through its fingers
[Applause]
don't worry about an earnest we all
still love you
despite lavish public spending on things
like sports stadiums and the Rock and
Roll Hall of Fame Cleveland in the 21st
century remains mired in a 1970s era
funk of double-digit unemployment and
population flight Cleveland has lost
more than half of its population since
1950 and routinely ranks as one of the
poorest big cities in the United States
more than 10,000 vacant homes in the
city act as a constant reminder of
Cleveland's economic catastrophe is a
Cleveland Renaissance possible of course
it is
[Music]
to get a handle on the kinds of problems
Cleveland is facing today we spoke to
Cleveland is from all walks of life then
we traveled country looking for
innovative ways to fix Cleveland schools
encourage redevelopment and bring back
businesses and people join us as we
learn how to fix the mistake on the lake
and other once great US city
[Music]